he always puts a caveat when he mentions
you that you're a bright guy I it's I
don't do you have any insight as to why
he just kind of mentions that every
single time you know it is it is
interesting when I met him in the Oval
Office during the whole Devin Nunes
midnight run thing yep uh he came out
from behind the Resolute desk where I
have to say he looked it looked like the
cover of Mad Magazine to me he
definitely did not belong in that
picture he comes out from behind the
desk the first thing he does when he
shakes my hand and says you know you do
a really good job presumably he means on
TV oh that that I understood because
that's what he that's what impresses him
how you do on TV
um but I tell you it was pretty awkward
because when somebody says something
like that to you you know you do a
really good job the first human impulse
is to want to say well so do you but
there was no way I could bring myself to
saying that so it was quite an awkward
pause after that comment